Dr. Cutters, on my call today, I checked my last Syrex, and I saw cashews,
Vasylid, are these the same as raw organic, have Vasylid?
These were not listed out of range, but are listed under the equivocal.
What does that mean? Not a good idea to eat? It was 1.69.
Okay, if I read bed burr correctly, that Syrex array 10.
So Syrex array 10 is testing 100 or so foods, some cooked, some raw,
because cooking some foods changes the protein in the food.
So you could actually have antibodies to cook something and not to raw something.
But with the nuts, the question is, do cashews, Vasylid, have, do raw organic, have Vasylid?
I'd say yes, they do, but the test that you did, it is now August, the test that you did,
I think was in January, you could basically throw this out, because if you've been
away from cashews for several months, it's a very good chance that you don't have those antibodies
anymore. So if you have self antibodies, let's say you have antibodies to your thyroid gland,
so we did a test on you, a complete thyroid profile, let's say you have thyroid globular antibodies,
common antibody to have, therefore you have an autoimmune disorder that's attacking your thyroid,
and you have to be careful of certain things, and not eat bloated and all this stuff,
and I have all this information about autoimmune thyroid called Hashimoto's on our autoimmune course.
But the music, this is an example. You can have those antibodies your whole life, no matter how well
you eat, no matter how well you support your thyroid, those antibodies may never go away.
But with foods, if you stay away from a food for a period of time, the majority of foods,
those antibodies will dissipate. They're not going to stay around. You know, you always will have
a thyroid, okay? So you could always have antibodies against it if you developed an autoimmune disease
against your thyroid. You don't always have cashews in your body. So if you stay away from cashews,
your B cells aren't going to be continuing to make antibodies against them, that's a whole idea
of eliminating those from your diet, and those can dissipate, almost always dissipate.
The only ones that tend not to dissipate is gluten because there's so much hidden gluten in stuff.
So, you know, many times people with a gluten sensitivity have to stay off gluten for their life.
If you have, we do a Cyrex-10 and you have other foods that show up in the yellow or in the red,
that's the equivocal or in the out of range, red. And you stay away from those for even three
months and you did the test again, those could be gone. So looking back at a test that you did six
plus months ago, it's kind of a mute point. If I had antibodies in the equivocal range to any food
six months ago, I would hesitate eating it now. If I had stayed away, if I've never stayed away from
them once and I was eating it every day, even after getting that test done, then you probably still have
antibodies that it might even be in the out of range, red zone. But if you stayed away from those
for the most part, they may be all gone. So it's kind of what you look at a test. It's like looking at a
blood test that you did eight months ago and making clinical decisions off that your body's changed.
It's not worth looking at the test, except to know trends, your body's changed. So I would not make
any clinical decisions based upon a food sensitivity test done more than a month or so ago, because your
body changes.